pablo lopez looking to piggyback
good start after his last one which came
against the phillies his 10th start of
the year
bounce back from the shortest outing of
his career a couple outings ago and
ending in two-thirds against atlanta
here's the one strike pitch
and thames grounds the ball to garrett
cooper
he feeds once again pablo lopez covering
at first base
pantry corbin goes to work 31 year old
corbin
6-3 and 210 pounds from clay new york
upstate
1-0 to miggy and miggy all over the
offering there deep into left that's got
a chance that one is gone
a lead-off home run for miguel rojas
his fourth of the year and second time
he's taking corbin
deep in early lead for miami well i'm
enjoying this this is the new theme for
the marlins right
comes in with the best numbers against
corbin a rojas home run
now nine for 21 with a couple of dingers
against patrick corbin
some contact there however it is
following right there
is a great play down the line that's
right
whoever's doing the analytics for the
marlins grounds crew
doubling his ball boys nailed that one
and john gomez will lead things off
and at 95 he gets it by gomes for his
first strikeout today
he's behind here 2-0 pitch and it's
lifted in the air to
center starling martay gets over and
gets under this
and a one two three inning for pablo
here in the second
pitch with a one nothing lead top of the
third now the 3-2 pitch return the
runner goes
swinging to miss wallop throw down to
second base high rodriguez
has to sky to pull it down and stephens
in there with a stolen base
but turner strikes out two down one two
pitch he's in on the hands and it's
blooped by third and over to make the
play brian anderson
a soft liner that looked like it might
have been headed into left field but
anderson got over moved back a few steps
and was able to pull it down
here comes miguel rojas who supplied the
only run in the game with his fourth
career first inning lead off home run
on 1-1 he smokes another ball deep down
the left field line that's going to one
hop up and over the wall into the
bullpen
a ground rule double for miguel rojas
and with two outs a man in third for
garrett cooper we'll see if coop
can pick miggy up toyota cooper is hit
well
deep right center field roll blaze going
back he's at the wall
goodbye garrett cooper has done it again
his fifth of the season makes it
three-nothing marlins
so the hits just keep on coming for the
marlins dame's the former brewer
the o2 and fame swings and misses that
was a
cut fastball and he records the
strikeout
it's his fourth in the game lopez really
working hard this
inning and a line drive out to right
center
cabrera scores garcia coming around
andrew stevenson has a four rbi series
and the nets are back to within a run
runner goes from first
chad's throw is sort of cut off by
rodriguez who then throws it back home
and they get kibu
marlins will maintain a one-run lead
because of that play
brinson at third base and one out two
balls in the strike to dickerson
grounds it right back to corbin who
can't make the play brinson was off
on contact it looked like and he's in
there safely now 4-2
louis brinson made that play happen he
made patrick corbin
speed through the play and not come up
with the baseball ground ball by the
first baseman base hit right field
for chad wallach coming around third
dickerson he's going to score and it's
5-2 miami
trey turner with one out one for eight
thus far
and one for nine with the strikeout that
time it's a fastball at the bottom of
the zone
five for lopez here's the pitch and
strike three called and you could hear
juan soto complain a one two three
fifth the marlins have two on and one
out for a guy who had a couple of three
run home runs
last night brian anderson and this one
toward left center field won't get out
but it will get down
for a base hit marte coming around third
another ribby for b.a
[Applause]
six to two marlins in the fifth i think
it's fair to say
brian anderson is seeing the ball pretty
well marlins up 6-2 here
in the sixth inning rojas to the plate
and that went into left
center field down for a base hit another
three
hit night for miguel rojas
so he needs a triple for the marlins
first cycle
that's toward right center field and hit
well turning
and they'll play this one off the wall
wallach around
third he'll score rojas is held at third
now he's on his way as the ball gets
away
kibum's throw is in time a two base hit
and an rbi for cooper seven to four here
within a three spot
and this one still going out to right
scoring easily will be kibum
blaze cruising to third so the nats get
back to within
seven to three kinsler
holds and delivers in the air
center field martay coming in
he makes the catch it's a marlins win
7-3